within a second you sent me this um this
is the fighter and the kid uh this is
gonna get mad look I already know I'm
gonna get mad because I pulled up
Brennan Shaw on the screen
um first off I want to point something
out because I'm going to cut this up and
whenever I cut this up I like to point
out to people that yeah bro we don't get
any puss I don't crush anything there's
no post crushing going on all right we
get it oh dude we don't crush push push
push Crush Crush Crush push thank you
for [ __ ] me you're welcome uh
where in cells were nerds nerds we're
[ __ ] nerds yeah not out getting buff
we're not crushing [ __ ] we're not
you're right you know what
um we're just jealous we're jealous of
Brandon shop I just want to establish
that I will never be jealous of a man in
a pair of mustard colored pants that
will never ever happen okay only his
only his people can kind of get away
with that [ __ ]
that's right out this episode is from
the fighter and the kid right after uh
Shane gillis's firing correct is this
when this is okay so we're gonna start
playing for him that's all I guess we
need to know
that's racist you're gonna have yellow
skin no that's not what I said well I'm
out of a dashboard of a dash of Asians
already in trouble you're in trouble
you're in trouble I like how I did get
it going for a race I got a lot of Asian
American people that hit me up and they
were
pissed not only were they pissed they
were like I'm not listening to the show
anymore oh God but but I understand
because I think I said the one thing
I've always said no hold on don't say
this no please
I said this before I've said that people
always forget because because Chinese
Americans Chinese
expat Chinese all over the world have
done incredibly well in every in every
culture Koreans have done incredibly
well Vietnamese done incredibly well in
every culture they've embedded
themselves in okay and I've always said
that they we don't talk enough about how
much they've been discriminated okay but
their culture seems to be he's a child
first off
coming from coming from people that two
two guys that do a show together right
can you imagine if I acted like or you
acted like Brandon while you were trying
to we've had raw heated arguments yeah I
know we have but the other one was never
going ah well no we we would I'll stop
talking and we get our point across sure
got heat but but imagine if you were
well I was saying this you just went
I get really pissed you are stupid uh
while you're talking
could I get the words out please
uh the kind of culture that gets them to
excel to the point where Harvard is see
they're suing Harvard on a class you are
rolling your pants up
also why does he have a koala on the
shoe
I don't get any of this the action suit
because apparently Harvard thinks there
are too many quote-unquitations
I understand I understand I've said that
before having said that let's go back to
whether or not somebody should lose
their job
because they made a comment from what I
heard
I'm doubling down from what I heard it
sounds like he said this is what other
people say about that particular house
yeah he kind of doubled down if anything
he's and I've said this from the jump
you should have been fired for having a
bad podcast the problem is it wasn't
funny and it was like Reckless and I get
it just wasn't funny
no let it let him
just let Royce have a moment to really
take because I I needed a minute too and
I needed a minute I I screamed actually
when I heard this the first time
you're not screaming it's it's
at least you're not screaming yes
is
he referring to the legions of legion of
skanks podcast is that is that who he's
referring no he's referring to Matt and
Shane's secret podcast which is the show
Shane Gillis is done with this other guy
I've got years
the joke that got Shane Gillis in
trouble that nobody ever wants to
discuss this is what got him in trouble
was
they were talking about racist slumlords
in in and how shangelis was talking
about why does Chinatown sock in every
city like Chinatown and I part of town
kind of sucks it does and they were
talking about how at the turn of the
century and before that in the old dimes
when we're bringing them over to build
the railroads and Sheen Gillis said
something like you know as as the slum
Lord was saying like oh yeah well that
part of town will just stick all the
chinks there that was the the premise of
the joke wasn't haha [ __ ] jinx it was
Shane Gillis was saying as a slumlord
like uh what's the shittiest part of
town we got over there you stick the
chinks over there it's Woody that was
the joke but this is it doesn't even
matter
the the fact that the man with the
lowest rated ever Showtime special
lowest rated ever in the history of
Showtime specials who had to offer CBD
oil for people to give it a better
review
the guy the first and I will and the guy
who himself made an insensitive Chinese
[ __ ] business I I hope this catches
on the first ever CTE comic
Brendan shop
is calling somebody else not funny look
I know you're going to people and you
guys are jealous fine wear whatever but
please with a straight face tell me you
think Brendan's funny name funnier than
Shane Gillis and I'm gonna say Shane's a
funny dude I've seen you stand up I do
actually think he's a funny guy right I
I really do think he's a funny guy
but even if you don't think he's funny
because my Greta is going to come out
here how dare you how dare you how dare
you I should be at SNL right now yeah in
the writing room how dare you made a
comment but he also I want to point out
that Brendan is also just a few weeks
removed
from his own extremely insensitive
tone-death portrayal of a specifically
Asian-American oh yeah
third how is
how is Shane Gillis making fun of
slumlords in New York and saying like
yeah we'll stick the chinks in the
terrible part of town how is he doing
that
worse and and more tone deaf than this
guy going Mr Sharp your fat lip I can't
give you oh I gotta give you a shot haha
he gave the doctor from UFC came in
wearing a rice farmer hat and he was
hiding in the trees
and then they show him oh I'm the U.S uh
UFC doctor I've been here for 12 years
now uh I'm sort of like uh sort of like
a dad to the boys around here
like it was literally the whitest Asian
guy ever
doubling down from what I heard it
sounded like he said this is what other
people say about that particular house
yeah he kind of doubled down if anything
he's and I've said this from the jump
you should have been fired for having a
bad podcast the problem is it wasn't
funny and it was like Reckless and I get
it just wasn't funny but I did have some
Asian Americans I think they're Asian
Americans could just be Asians DM me and
go Brennan get your opinion all good
how would you feel if you use the n-word
replace what he said the still fine
[ __ ] and I like saying it let's replace
and the only answer should have been I
wouldn't have cared I am no no no no no
this isn't like Faker put on for the
radio I am [ __ ] pissed now
I don't like saying it
what's more offensive Brendan
that is way worse worst pain in your
life I want you to ask black people
what's more offensive if I say a joke
with the word [ __ ] in it or if you go
up and talk or if I start singing Mammy
with black face on you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you want holy unfunny I just I just
wanna [ __ ] no I just want to say
though it's like I got a lot of emails
from people right and it's like you
can't I would never use the n-word on
stage you know what I mean but boy I'll
sure do like me some watermelon yeah
whoa whoa whoa go back to using the N
word
please go back to using the n-word
because boy I sure do like me some fried
chicken balls like that go on stage and
start talking like the crows from Dumbo
I sure do not I sure don't like that N
word no way no household
this is this is [ __ ] unbelievable to
me this was gonna make you mad be Asians
DM me and go Brennan get your opinion
all good
how would you feel if you use the n-word
replace what he said the the chank [ __ ]
I don't like saying it let's replace
chinkles N word would you still defend
I'm like oh I wouldn't well then they
went around twice like I literally had
this dialogue this guy goes isn't that
weird you think it's all good because
they [ __ ] because you don't think
that's as hard I didn't think it was I
would defend the n-word I I would defend
it I would defend any so right there it
goes to show you that this [ __ ] brain
damage brain damage UFC loser
this [ __ ] guy doesn't even understand
comedy you should defend it you should
defend it whether he said [ __ ] whether
he said [ __ ] whether he said whatever
the [ __ ] even if the joke wasn't funny
it being funny you deciding something's
not funny does not constitute constitute
it being allowed or not that's not how
it works yeah you defend him if they say
the n-word yeah you defend him if they
say [ __ ] yeah you defend him no matter
[ __ ] what you're a phony bit Brendan
you're a [ __ ] phony who never paid
your dues in the comic game you sucking
Joe Rogan's balls all the way down your
throat just to be sitting here with your
Forever 21 jeans
any and look I honestly don't even care
about all that I don't oh I do no no I
really don't I don't care when somebody
gets lucky and has the right friends and
kind of like benefits from that I don't
care like if I was friends with some
famous [ __ ] I would take
advantage of it too but my problem is
that he's only been doing this for like
a year he is a terrible special he did
the same thing that he's he's kind of
like whoa he's pretending like he didn't
just do the Chinese thing he's
pretending like his special wasn't
universally panned right right
I don't care if you get lucky dude get
lucky in life enjoy that [ __ ] but when
you start already like a half a year in
and you're going I personally just think
it's not funny and that's like that's
not what we like we comics
should be doing like I don't care if you
get lucky in your Charmed Life and
you're selling out theaters make a
million dollars but you don't get to sit
on the High Council now and be like you
know what I mean there's a reason why
they told Anakin Skywalker he needed to
go [ __ ] chill out and sit at the kids
table for a while you know what I mean
like there's this idea of you're not
ready you're not ready to first of all
it shouldn't nobody should be telling
anybody what uh they're allowed to joke
around about but that being said this
guy's gonna sit on the panel and decide
what we're allowed to joke about
this is this is
this is why I think La Comics are trash
this is why La Comics are trash and
actually if you want a really good uh
timestamp
because this was something I didn't
discover until after I sent you this
video I discovered this last night
if you go to 56.30
well let me finish this very well oh I
will it's good I don't use that no no I
don't say it's good but I I didn't think
you but they go even if he was saying
out of context the n-word would you
still defend him oh I wouldn't have well
oh I get it well I get it then I kind of
get it I think you can say any word
depending on context well I see I don't
I don't think see I don't but okay why
is he saying it like I'm sorry whether
you like Brian Callan or not Brian
Callan is an actual established touring
comedian who actually did like you got
lucky he's not meeting Rogan but he was
on Mad TV before he met Rogan but the
guy had a career but what I'm saying is
he Rogan helped him a lot coming back of
course yeah but the man Paid Dues the
man did Shady Club gigs the man [ __ ]
scraped by until he got to Mad TV like
he did a lot of gigs before now being
like oh cool I mean we're Rogue and I
can sell tickets so he didn't just get
handed some [ __ ] he's he's earned it
so they those guys have a different
mentality dude
you can use the n-word well I I think
you can use the N word if you use I
think it's context right but also I see
I don't think you can that's fine but
but I I I would describe but see I don't
think you can but I also think it's uh
because it's a product of the
environment I grew up in yeah when I was
young gotcha where it's mainly
African-American so like that word
carried so much weight but the product
of where you grew up
has nothing to do whether where other I
could use the word or he could use the
word or anybody could use the word and
you know Callan I'll even go a little
further
I see where calendar is coming from but
it doesn't matter the context
like you should be able to use whatever
whatever word you want in a state
especially if we're talking in a
stand-up set or in a podcast when you're
joking like
it doesn't really matter it shouldn't
matter I mean it does matter obviously
now it matters because you'll get
deleted and stuff but we've always
thought that it it shouldn't matter
what was the timestamp again 50 56 30
now you wanna I I now this is just me
speculating now okay I I can't uh say
this for sure but I am of the opinion
that Brian Callan has turned a corner
and I think he's had it with Brendan
Shaw as a person as as every I think he
goes I think he's thinking like I used
to do this show with christelia I like
Miss cristalia I hate this [ __ ] me
dead he he need the money here's what's
happening with him I think you saw the
base frequency documentary
and was like
you know what I should have taken the
Netflix gig why didn't I
because he told me not to to sell shirts
how come wait but he got a Showtime wait
and and I think that stuff is is eating
away at him I really believe that I I
believe that it's somebody says this
podcast won't last long I don't know how
much longer this this podcast will last
I have no idea they're making money you
know they're selling merch and [ __ ] but
it's gonna come in time where it's not
enough money you know what I mean yeah
kellen's gonna go I can't do this
anymore because I guarantee you Callie
makes way more money on the road yeah he
does doing this [ __ ] but I want you to
observe Brendan's shop to try to try to
pass off a little white Brendan chaublay
and I want to I want you to watch as
Brian Callan
tests him he doesn't press him but he
does he he pushes a little bit yeah
watch watch this you're gonna love this
Talon he's doing pretty well Big Sean's
five six why do you think they call him
Big Sean I don't know man I'm not
packing a [ __ ] Detroit bazooka okay
Detroit bazooka yeah dude you call it a
Detroit bazoo from Detroit bro what's
your [ __ ] mouth yeah
dude good I'm proud of them just keep
doing it dude just do you know Pete yeah
how do you know him uh just around is he
is he hanging I've never seen him once
he goes there sparingly yeah I don't
know we've just like being cool with his
Nelly uh the old New York is on Saturday
Night Live but he comes out here too is
he still on us now oh yeah
he's great man I've always been a fan of
him he's always been nice to me it was
great to me
would be terrible
because I'm sure you're gonna pick up
different things than I did Brenda would
be terrible at poker oh he's the worst
liar
but he's like you notice he took the hat
off and he's like yeah I know like from
uh he's let me put it you know like yeah
Saturday night I know him from like
around from around around the place
Brandon so has you're right he's such a
bad poker face he's acting the way I
would act if I were in a role playing a
guy lying yeah you know what I mean yeah
no he's been at the store before yeah no
no experiment I've seen him around
whatever
thank you
look at Brian callan's body language
he's had it with him look at his body
language he's like had it look whether
you like this show or not whatever but
look at his body language he's if Mike
and I ever had that look for each other
doing this show you would know oh [ __ ]
there's a problem there's times we'll
get like mildly annoyed at each other
for a minute but Brian callan's been
like this this whole episode he's like
yeah
you know him you know it's an SNL
where's he live what's his zip code it's
was that not weird though it was it was
like it was like SVU when they're trying
to break a suspect
not even break them but just try to get
them to commit to a lie that they know
is a lie that's the other thing the cops
will do they'll be like okay so yeah you
said uh it's the DMV right you said
Thursday you were there 4 P.M
all right I'll be back all right enjoy
that soda I'll be right back and then
you're like uh what do they have they
have they have definitive proof that I
was not at the damage at four o'clock
yesterday they don't need to get you in
the actual crime it just got to get you
going no no I was there four o'clock
Thursday you can prove it well I have a
lunch with Cliff Huxtable at the Four
Seasons I I gotta go
um and then you do that weird like uh
and then you do a weird like uh quip
like they do on SVU and then you go grab
the keys and they're like where you
going partner and you're like
it's time to go renew my my driver's
license I guess I got to go renew those
tags I'll get it he's going to go to the
DMV yeah
but this is he's sweet oh yeah I love it
look at that the whole like he's at the
ah yeah nice we hang out all the time
you got
I love his videos he started writing his
nails like that's which I know I do too
I'm not saying don't trust me I know
people complain about her all the time
suck a dick
but his nail biting is like my nail
biting is just a compulsive thing I do I
can't help it that's a he doesn't want
to be there dude oh yeah I don't think
he wants to be he's he's [ __ ] had it
with Brendan
Ariana Grande started with him
he just does look like he might have a
big dick I don't know why he just does
like lanky you know lanky yeah that's
how it goes
dick dude just watch Brian the whole
time though that's what I'm doing keep
your eyes on him I feel like the hello
darkest mild friend should be play The
Sound of Silence should be playing in
itself it's over this man and I just
picked up on this last night and I'm
like holy [ __ ] and then I was like wait
yeah we haven't played that clip yet so
I figured as soon as we played it I was
gonna go remember that other spot
fuckboy Falls in though dude
I don't know what that means
oh we're picking this up oh boy you got
you you're on to something my friend he
has yeah I don't know what you mean but
yeah I had it with him you know where
it's just where you know where you can
identify and go
this is beyond repair now
like uh decisions already been made in
Brian Collins said it's not a matter of
if just when
oh the energy in there is [ __ ]
awkward
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] winter
looking forward to that yeah
look at me like that
let's go hey keep stop stop staring at
me I like that man you're looking at me
kind of for a long time sorry I just
want you to be part of [ __ ] boy
I am and that bothers me you missed a
hot girl summer though you know what you
were never mind that was a hot girl
summer you're part of hot girls summer
yeah for a minute no you're still
partner
Summer's over though you know oh yeah
Felicity Huffman leads Court after
sentencing 14 days
is that not
that's two guys that are [ __ ] done
with each other oh that is that is
they're done that show's gonna be gone
soon that is a hard watch man that
really is uh I'll tell you to enjoy that
no no I had to turn it back around
because Royce was getting too mad and
I'm like all right let me cheer Royce up
go to 56 30.
he's at it with him Brian callan's gonna
come to the dark side